Vsauce Kevin here put on your hohoho
Miam t-shirt and get warm in your
sweater of Santa dropping toilet
presence because this is a special
Christmas edition of the move prepare
for the holidays and make yourself some
festive toast with this Christmas print
toaster and then have some tea with a
candy cane tea infuser if you're more of
a coffee drinker check out this cool
project recently funded on Kickstarter
the new machine is able to roast grind
and brew your coffee so you can buy
coffee beans direct from the growers
giving you the freshest cup of joe
possible for something equally as hot
suck on one of these sriracha candy
canes then cool yourself down with some
leg lamp ice cubes from a Christmas
story and now that you're awake and cool
let's do some cool decorating by growing
snow this kit lets you add the gross
snow pack it to water and then watch the
magic happen
make your tree come alive with these
googly eye ornaments that can go right
next to your Sigmund Freud ornament to
analyze all the gifts you get like this
twerking Einstein now let's get back to
work and pick out some presents first
download the browser extension tab for a
cause that will earn money for a charity
of your choice with every tab you open
so you can give to those in need while
you do your shopping then arm yourself
with this beef jerky gun that finally
allows you to pull a trigger to make me
meet up with your friends on this cool
electric scooter called Kubo that was
designed to give riders ample amounts of
storage space to haul things around this
bike exhaust system will turn an
ordinary bike into a motorbike or at
least make it sound like long and you
can add these bike mittens to keep your
hands toast to you while riding around
on those cold wintery days stay warm
with Harry Potter and Game of Thrones
inspired winter wear sent to me by
vsauce fan Jackie she makes her own line
of knitted accessories that help you see
yourself as your favorite characters
visualize sounds in your car with these
cool sound activated car stickers for
the scientist in the family you can
order an heirloom chemistry set
reminisce
of the Gilbert chemistry set from the
50s that comes with real chemicals and
equipment start learning had a program
early with primo a playful physical
programming interface that teaches kids
the logic of programming without
requiring the ability to read for your
four-legged friend pick up this dog
treat PEZ dispenser and for everyone you
don't like just give them the gift of
nothing literally but if you do that you
might need to get yourself this bah
humbug blank candy came after all that
shopping you'll need to unwind in this
Dutch tub it's a wood burning hot tub
that uses the heat from the fire and
natural circulation to allow you to
relax anywhere or just relax with a beer
in the shower that you conveniently hold
in your shower koozie but if you're not
in your own bathroom you might want to
invest in this public toilet survival
kit store all of your awesome gifts in
this storage bed or use it to do a Santa
stakeout with this handy kit that has
everything you need to sneak up on old
st. Nick himself which of course will go
great with your tactical stocking don't
worry about spilling gravy on yourself
with these gravy flavored candy canes
but if you do spill something just wear
silic a shirt that cleans itself because
the hydrophobic nanotechnology creates a
microscopic layer of air that forms
between the liquid and the fabric so
finally drink your eggnog out of cups
that let you pick your nose and grumpy
cat wants you to know your gift is in
the litter box and I'm gonna leave you
with the gift of game loot with Jake
over on vsauce3 and as always thanks for
watching
[Music]